[Music]
I'm the one
so a lot has happened since uh the last
time we did a live podcast right we
crossed a million Subs which is great to
everybody thank you to everyone that
subscribed
and uh uh that was pretty annoying time
but uh fantastic now we're deaf we uh uh
the Tate interviews we haven't spoken
since we came back oh yeah Andrew and
Tristan Tate's uh interview we had a
good time there and then we just got
news right now this morning that they
got charged with and we'll talk about
that as well but today's guest is a
special one I've seen his stuff and a
message you gave oh my God I mean it was
absolutely bonkers the message you gave
let me first properly introduce Our
Guest today then I'll show the clip and
if you don't know the name Constantine
kissing you're gonna know after you
watch a couple of these clips you're
gonna say I saw that speech and I shared
it with my friends it was absolutely
amazing he has written for a number of
Publications including the spectator The
Daily Telegraph standpoint on issues
relating to Tech censorship what culture
comedy and culture War Topics in the
past but currently publishes articles on
these sub on his sub stack okay he has
co-hosted trigonometry since 2018 a
YouTube channel and podcast featuring
fellow comedian co-host Frances Foster
Rob if you can pull up one of the clips
here
uh let's go to the one where he goes
from exactly 214. this is you giving
this message this is where at Oxford
Union and he's he's invited and he's not
necessarily speaking to people that
agree with what he has to say just go
ahead and play you'll see what I'm
talking about
I want to talk to those of you who are
woke and who are open to rational
argument
a small minority I accept
because one of the tenets of witnesses
of course that your feelings matter more
than the truth but I believe in you I
believe there are those of you here who
are work who are open to rational
arguments so let me make one we are told
that your generation cares more than any
other about one issue in particular and
that issue is climate change
we're told that many of you suffer from
climate anxiety
you wish to save the planet and for
tonight and tonight only I will join you
I will join you in worshiping at the
feet of Saint Greta of climate change
let us all accept right here right now
that we are living through a climate
emergency and our stocks of polar bears
are running extremely low I join you in
this view I truly do now what are we to
do about this huge problem facing
Humanity
what can we in Britain do
we can only do one thing you know why
this country is responsible for two
percent of global carbon emissions which
means that if Britain was to sink into
the sea right now it would make
absolutely no difference to the issue of
climate change you know why because the
future of the climate is going to be
decided in Asia and in Latin America by
poor people who couldn't give a [__]
about saving the planet
no thank you
it's going to be decided by four people
on the podcast thank you yes love the
work you're doing love love the fact
that you're going out to pushing the
envelope through a logic through reason
and forcing them to come back and say
you don't make sense but you do so uh
good to have you and for the audience
that doesn't know your background how
did you go from you know where you are
today but how did you first get started
maybe take a minute and share your
background with us okay so born late
Soviet Union uh most of my family uh had
to flee or Escape for one reason or
another mainly for saying the wrong
thing so it kind of runs in the family
with me
um and uh that informs a lot of My World
Views because many of the things that
are happening now in in Western
Societies in the UK and to some extent
in America I see is parallel to what we
had in the Soviet Union so for example
just give you one brief example
political correctness do you guys know
where it comes from political
correctness we had never had anything to
do with being nice to people not
offending anybody anything like that
political correctness was invented in
the Soviet Union for one reason and one
reason only to say to people what you're
saying is factually correct but it's
Politically Incorrect and that meant it
was inconvenient to the party line of
the day it was a way of enforcing an
ideology and everybody else my
grandfather late uh late Soviet Union
said the wrong thing about the Soviet
invasion of Afghanistan boom lost his
job his wife fired from her job again is
that so unfamiliar to the world that we
increasingly live in now so that was the
thing but look you were right I started
as a stand-up comedian in the UK I was
just doing stand-up didn't really care
about any of this stuff
and then in 2018 I was gigging at a
comedy club some students saw me uh they
invited me to help raise money for
charity at their college uh and when
they invited me they sent me what they
called a behavioral agreement contract
which said that they had a zero
tolerance policy on racism sexism
classism ageism ableism homophobia by
far be a transferred by xenophobia
islamophobia anti-religion anti-atheism
and it also said that all jokes must be
respectful and kind before you go before
you go this is 2018. this is pre-covered
okay the antithesis of what comedy is
supposed to be pushing the envelope
right and I look I'll be honest with you
I thought this is kind of a weird thing
that's happening in comedy because
comedy is a very kind of progressive
industry generally most people who go
into stand up are kind of more like on
the creative side they're not business
people and so they think in this kind of
left liberal way which is cool you know
I've got no problem with that but I
thought it was just me that felt this
stuff was a bit weird I turned it down I
tweeted about it to like like a thousand
followers that I had at the time and
this story goes Super viral around the
world so give you an example on the day
that this story went uh big it was the
second most read story on the BBC News
website the biggest News website in the
UK the number one story was the Prime
Minister of our country had nearly been
removed from office by her own party
right so that's the equivalent of Joe
Biden like imagine this right now Joe
Biden nearly gets impeached by the
Democrats and the second biggest story
in the country is no name comic turns
down underpaid charity gig from two-bit
college right it's crazy right and I got
when that happened I got thousands of
messages from people all over different
Industries different people different
places America the UK anglosphere
Australia New Zealand who were all
telling me about stuff that's happening
in their workplace and that's when I
realized like this culture that's going
on right now it's not just me that's
crazy and thinks it's weird this is a
real thing out there in the world and so
my YouTube show trigonometry my co-host
and I we speaking to people you know the
Douglas Murrays the Jordan Petersons
they're a bunch of different people
trying to understand what is going on
why are people thinking like this why is
this going on and that's kind of my
journey to where I am today so what
conclusion have you come up with with
all these people you've been
interviewing why do you why do you think
they're thinking the way they're
thinking it doesn't make a lot of a
logical sense just yesterday this uh the
guy from Star Wars what's his name
there's been a Twitter award the last 40
years yeah
he tweets this yesterday and I asked a
innocent question wanting to become
smarter as a guy that's not a scientist
hoping he can help me out but uh I
didn't hear back from him so George if
you're watching this please help me get
a little bit more clear on this so he
posts yesterday on Twitter I am now
following Peter hotez and every decent
person who believes in signs not
quackery too and then I said George
according to science how many genders
are out there I haven't gotten a
response back nothing right so I'm
wondering how do we get here like this
stuff is logical right it's common sense
but it sounds like the other side is
creating a lot of momentum with things
that make absolute no sense why is that
well I think if you look at the stats on
what happens post 2014 when social media
really takes off yeah this is a disease
of social media this idea that there's
an infinite number of genders because in
the disembodied online world you can say
that right so the more we go into living
online the easier it is to believe
things that aren't true because there's
no hard test like if I pick up this
bottle of water and let it go we know
what's going to happen because it
happens in the real world but how do you
falsify that how do you test that right
so I think that part of this is It's a
disease of social media and then we've
also got to position and John Jonathan
height writes about this in the cuddling
of the American mind where we've created
a generation successive generations of
people who've not been brought up
properly and victimhood is now currency
right again this is an online phenomenon
if I you know I'm a first general
Russian immigrant in the UK okay a dark
skin if I say well you know people have
been racist to me which they have right
therefore here's some things that are
true people are much more likely to
listen to that even though there's no
reason to actually take out that my
opinion any more seriously than anybody
else's right so we've got ourselves into
a position where people are rewarded for
being victims and their claims about
reality are given more credibility
because of that
so you get recognition for being a
victim social media creates the eyeballs
let me get a little bit of attention and
that's causing other people to do the
same because it's getting attention 100
that's simple 100 what about and the
problem with social media right is it
rewards ideas that sound good
but aren't true and it punishes ideas
that are true but don't sound good give
you an example if you go online and you
say look you live in a systemic
patriarchy blah blah blah blah blah and
that's why you are where you are well
that's really reassuring because
nothing's my fault right what about you
go online and you say no one's coming to
save you your life is your
responsibility oh I gotta I gotta take
responsibility for my life now I've got
to go out there and do stuff I gotta go
out there and overcome things well I
don't want to hear that message it's
much more comfortable to hear that
nothing is in you know I don't control
anything I am where I am because Society
is this way
what's going on in the UK these days
because I think I feel like the reason
that you have become so prominent is
because of your perspective born and
raised in the Russia Jewish
anti-Semitism I just came back from
Israel literally I landed a handful of
hours ago I was with a Russian girl
friend of mine who's basically saying
that she was told her entire life do not
tell people you're Jewish do not tell
people you're Jewish she came to Israel
now she's like screaming from the
rooftops hey I'm proud to be Jewish yada
yada you moved to the UK you said you
dealt with racism anti-Semitism
um
never no no okay but look I'm not I'm
not I'm Jewish I'm like a quarter Jewish
I'm not practicing so it's it's not a
figure yeah yeah but but being muzzled
is my question so you started the
conversation off about propaganda
basically started or not or political
correctly started in in Russia
propaganda yes propaganda too no problem
one and the same exactly but what are
you seeing going on in the UK these days
because essentially my question is this
it used to be people on the right like I
grew up in Miami and um it was it it was
usually like Evangelical Christians
basically saying no that's that's that's
against the Bible you can't do this and
I remember there was a supreme court
lawsuit against like my favorite rap
group of the time two Live Crew as nasty
as they want to be they won the lawsuit
and now it seems like it's coming from
the left and the extreme left is
basically trying to
marginalize voices and silence voices
when it used to be 20 30 years ago
coming from the right what are you
seeing in the UK is the same thing the
United States give us your perspective
you know what it's I'm so glad you made
that point because this is the thing
that I always say is like I grew up
watching Bill Hicks and George Carlin
make jokes about religion and then not
be allowed to perform or being censored
and whatever right and I keep saying I
long for the day when I can go back to
being like someone in the center Center
left where I'm railing against religious
conservatives you're going you can't say
that you can't joke about that right
like that's how it used to be I'm really
comfortable in that world and it's
flipped because this as you say there's
an ideology on on on the left now that
tells people that their feelings matter
more than the truth you know and and
it's I'm so grateful you played a clip
of my speech because uh right at the end
there's something people actually don't
know about that speech and it's been
seen by like 300 million people or more
around the world is if you look closely
right at the end there's a guy uh who's
very physically disabled uh and he he
can only use one arm and I'm talking
right at the end of the speech about the
fact that I'm not saying what I'm saying
uh for any other reason that I want
young people to get stuck in to to lean
into something if you think climate
change is a big problem go fix it go
study go learn go build an organization
do whatever it is right and this guy uh
with one arm he's clapping his own
shoulder right when I'm talking about
don't be a victim and he came up to me
afterwards and we had a conversation and
I'm not gonna lie it was kind of hard to
understand that's how physically
difficult it is for him to communicate
right but this is a guy that believes
that that you should never be a victim
to
what an incredible thing to see that I
love that and right next to him is a
bunch of young people fully abled from
Rich backgrounds at one of the best
universities in the world right who
think that they are oppressed I mean
give me a break guys yeah and you know
you know what's amazing you say that if
you listen to the whole speech uh uh I
love how you you keep taking I'm not
going to do this no I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna say I told you so and there's
no way I'm gonna do this I mean it was
shots after shots zero did you have
notes when you gave this talk did you
have and I had them there but I didn't
use them okay so so I'm like he is not
looking at a teleprompter and it was
what nine or ten minutes go go to the
part go to the clip of
um show the one with him and Bill Maher
because this part about Bill Maher I'm
on Andrew Schultz podcast and we're
talking about America hmm
and I said you know there's a lot of
people that are confused they keep
talking about you know you be careful
with nationalists be careful with
nationalists you got to be careful with
nationalists these nationalists are
terrible nationalists right like okay
what is the antonym of nationalism it's
globalism right so would I rather be
proud of the country I represent or
globally now man I'm going to represent
the country I'm a part of I'm a proud
American we're proud to be living in a
country like this and you go on Bill
Martin you say this to him which is
incredibly powerful by the way this is
by money smart Matt's Apollo posted this
can you play this clip real quick Rob
people in other parts of the world are
not teaching their young children to
hate their own country
[Music]
to do this how is how is the West going
to do in the Battle of civilizations
because that's what we're in right the
Chinese want to thrive the Russians want
to thrive and they are teaching their
children to be strong to be confident to
go out there to learn science instead of
you know equity and diversity
[Music]
and a bridge doesn't work very well if
it's built in diversity instead of mass
so
foreign
how was this
how is this not logical a reasonable
message
um how is this offensive to certain
people you know it's amazing today when
you look at uh well I went and gave a
talk at this school with uh it's a
Christian School I'm giving this message
and the guy that talks before me was the
dean
and he goes up there and he says listen
you know we have to be careful with the
way we talk about America because
America has a history and it's not
perfect and it's not this but you know
in in at the same time we are doing our
best and there's a lot of things we have
to figure out and he's kind of almost
like apologizing about America
so I get up there and I say first of all
I want to thank you for giving me the
stage here to talk to these 600 kids in
the audience fantastic I said well let
me start off with one thing here
everybody needs to know America is the
greatest country in the world
the greatest country in the world you
see certain people get uncomfortable and
I kept saying it let me say it one more
time never apologize about the greatness
of America and how it positively
impacted the entire world you know what
was well I had no idea what the reaction
was going to be everybody stood up
these kids who are 12 13 14 15 16 17
years old want to love their country
right they want to be proud of what
they're representing right yet this is
controversial today right and this is
why I'm saying what I'm saying this is
why I wrote my book because you've got
to understand like people keep saying to
me you know even when I turn down that
contract this is just some college kids
what are you you know this is no big
deal but college kids grow up right and
then they go into business and then they
Implement a bunch of stuff and the
problem with with this ideology is it's
fundamentally anti-west it's anti-merit
and it's anti-truth right and you put
those three things together you put that
into law you've got yourself a really
big problem so I think from my
perspective and this is how I think
about it Patrick if you thought that
your country was bad okay
why would you defend it why would you
teach its values to your children okay
now play that movie Forward over
Generations if we keep teaching people
to hate their country if we keep uh you
know causing divisions between different
races between men and women and all of
that what do you think is going to
happen you think the world is a vacuum
in which as we get weaker nothing
changes that's not how the world works
right and so I think it's really
important that the West remains strong
because if if you're on the left and
this is what I always say to people if
you're one of these Progressive people
you care about equality for gay people
where is a better place to be gay than
the West yeah where's a better place to
be trans than the West yeah go be gay in
Iran see what happens yeah where's a
better place to be a woman
what are we comparing ourselves to right
and the same thing with our history and
this is why the the conversation about
our history Western history is the
number one conversation for me right
because if we cannot change the way we
talk about our history we will not
change the way that we are going into
the future and if we teach children that
our history's like to your point wrong
and bad oh you get to a dark place very
quickly with that yeah where's the pride
let me ask you one more thing this this
like the sort of this ideology this
apology tour that we're on in the west
United States the UK the Western World
um we're basically coming to terms with
our sins of the past yes slavery racism
anti-Semitism the list goes on and on
homophobe
but yet in the Far East or in Russia and
China and the mulas in Iran
um they're they're proud to be where
they're from but then let's go deeper
you don't think they've done stuff to be
ashamed of
how many tens of millions of Chinese
were killed under Mao how many tens of
millions of people were stuck in the
gulags
um with with Communism with Stalin and
Lenin yet they're still able to be proud
and not teach their kids to be ashamed
of the past Germany has how many
um I mean you go to Auschwitz and you go
to Poland and they they have remembrance
of the Holocaust basically owning the
sins of the past yet still being proud
of their Heritage and their future why
can't we do both in the United States
why can't we say listen there's some
things we've done in the past but we are
still the greatest country every country
has sins why does it have to be a binary
option of whether good or we're bad
every country has a history like this
that's right and I think that context is
really really important actually right
because you've got to contextualize it's
like my buddy Francis always says what
you think the Ottomans were woke yeah
you know what I mean right and you know
we talk about slavery and stuff it's not
like the British or the Americans in
invented slavery slavery was a universal
institution throughout human history and
the British Empire actually ended
slavery it's the first the first time
that that really happened right
um you know my ancestors were basically
slaves in the gulags in the middle of
the 20th century so we got to
contextualize our history and say and
and you're right though we got to learn
from it right we've got to say hold our
hands up we got this wrong because it's
the same on an individual level there's
no one in this room who hasn't made
terrible mistakes in their life right
but imagine you just focus on that and
you never actually tried to get better
you never actually tried to look into
the future with hope and optimism just
and sort of like Naval gazed about how
you mess something up a long time ago
doesn't work and also this other point
I'm making the book you cannot be held
responsible for the sins of your
ancestors you can only be responsible
for things you yourself have done right
right so we got to make sure that in the
modern society we don't make the
mistakes that they made but we can't I
can't be held responsible for something
my grandfather did right
um and and so we just we need to have a
healthier view of our societies while
learning the lessons of the past for
sure and how much of is it is this
victim culture monetizable oh meaning
there's money in being a victim whether
it's reparations whether it's um uh Ubi
whether it's stimulus checks just like
the more of a victim mentality you had
ah there's more money uh Dylan Mulvaney
I'm a trans guy let me go get a 10
million contract from Bud Light all
right San Francisco certain places in
California handing out five million
checks for California wasn't even a
slave state like so it's like it's
monetizable victimhood where I don't
know how it works in other countries
like that how much of it is just there's
a money play here well the big one isn't
to me like you know diddle Mulvaney is
an idiot and whatever let him uh crack
on with whatever he wants to do but what
about the corporate world where you've
got these people coming in doing d-i-e I
call it die training right for people 20
grand for an hour seminar telling white
people that they're guilty like that
what's the value in that what are we
doing how are we improving the world and
by the way the all the evidence is down
you can look this up all the studies
show diversity inclusion and Equity
training makes people more racist
that's great that's true expound about
that please because that's a that's a
major point someone comes in and just
goes oh this is your skin color you must
be bad how does that make you feel right
it kind of works like that and look it
up if you want I mean that that's a fact
right the studies are showing that this
ideology being pushed on to people just
makes them more resentful it's not
actually healing and divides in society
and that's what I'm about I I'm like
look people especially in America man
like this is a country that people from
all over the world come to and they buy
into one idea one idea this is the
American dream we can all have some
things that we share and then we're free
to live our lives as much as possible
the way we want right why antagonize
people against each other I just don't
it doesn't make any sense to me well I
don't I don't think that that's anything
new though right divide and conquer Art
of War yeah but but the point is what is
the outcome I mean is the outcome to
destroy the West well that's been a
vision for a lot of people for a long
time it's not like it's anything new you
know if if you look at it just purely
from competitive standpoint you want to
beat the other guy right in the NBA you
know uh they would they would do things
and they would say Hey you know that guy
doesn't like you and he did this with
this and he did this with your girl to
create a lot of trauma you know before
game that's coming up and then boom they
don't know how to play with each other
game is over right you know this happens
in sports this happens in politics
there's somebody in the Trump campaign
that's leaking information there's
somebody in this campaign that's leaking
you keep saying this now nobody trusts
nobody because you wanted this is a very
effective strategy that's been around
for a very very long time Confucius
divide and conquer but for what is it
purely for America to fall and what is
at the cost of that the other day I'm at
uh Bermuda three days ago I'm getting a
massage and this lady I said so where
are you from she says uh I'm from
Hungary so are you from Hungary yeah I
said okay what do you think about this
guy George Soros he's from your country
no and she stops she gets angry what the
sweetest lady he is
do you know how bad of a man he is he is
evil tell me you don't like him so I'm
like well I don't know much about now
I'm just kind of playing along I'm
trying to find out yeah why is he evil
what did he do to you do you know what
he did when he was 14 years old he was
helping the Nazis and he said it was
okay now she's feeding me all this stuff
right but what is the outcome is the
outcome just to destroy America and if
yes who wins because some of the people
that are destroying America are not from
the outside they're destroying from the
inside and they're living here Bingo and
this is what I was gonna say I don't
know if you guys are familiar familiar
with Yuri besmanov this is a KGB of
course yes absolutely so this is the
point that he made you cannot
destabilize a society that doesn't want
to destabilize itself right and this is
my point let other people try to
indoctrinate Americans into this way of
thinking but if we have a strong immune
system it's like a virus you're gonna be
fine right so that's why you got to
teach people yes these are the things
that happen in our history let that's
how we and now we got over it now we
don't have slavery now we don't we we of
the least racist places in the West in
the history of the world we're working
to get better all the time that's why we
should be proud of ourselves right if we
can do that it doesn't matter what
anyone else is trying to do you said it
yourself America and the West together
the greatest civilization in the history
of the world right and if if we want to
maintain that we've got to be
comfortable with being the most powerful
and the greatest civilization in the
history of the world but but do you
think it's a concerted effort
Constantine from other countries like
China with social media and everything
because like as an American I feel it
we're slowly going like it doesn't help
when the the government when you watch
the White House and you have the White
House saying stuff about trans and so
what reported the other day asks a
question like hey so parents that have
like girls in school and they're
competing against these men are
concerned that you know if it's
wrestling and gets hurt automatically uh
Korean Jean-Pierre she's like that
you're that's transphobic you're gonna
injure people like do you feel like if
the government the highest level level
is pro all this movement are we screwed
or like what I'm trying to figure out
are we screwed and if it's coming from a
different from different countries
that's trying to like embed their ideas
into our idea man I hear you and uh it's
so funny when I go back and visit with
family back home and I tell them about
like the biggest conversation in the
west now is what is a woman they all
just look at me like I'm insane you mean
in Russia well for all Russia Ukraine
Armenia go to different places where my
family are and they all look at me like
I'm making it up they can't they can't
believe it
um look in the UK on the trans issue
we've actually made quite a lot of
progress so literally in the last few
weeks they've basically the National
Health Services then said that they're
not going to do any uh gender surgery
they're not going to give hormones to
kids Etc so it's possible to to push
back against it I think and we certainly
have done in the UK
uh and you know I always believe in the
power of reason you know uh I know I
mean that is that is scary to me that
that's the way the conversation is
getting happier uh and I I struggle to
understand how serious people can do
that I've said from day one the trans
thing is what will break wokeness
completely yeah because once you start
messing with people's kids yeah and once
you go to that level of like susp like
you know you the idea that you can
change your sex by incantation by saying
you know Abracadabra Stacy
that's hilarious yeah right like that
that that doesn't sell with the ordinary
person exactly right and when does it
stops kind of like what what's the next
thing because now it's on the gender
situation where if I say I'm a and if
you don't you're you could get canceled
you get you know taken off a YouTube and
you get strikes and it's like it's
insane how it's just that's the like
where's the goal post gun here let's go
into the story let's just go into a few
of the stories I want to get into that
right now Korean jump here uh uh said
dangerous to say transgender kids can
hurt girls in sports you know when logic
and this is the press secretary because
if she says it you know it's right so
here's a couple things that's going on
in different states another state just
banned transgender athletes from women's
college sports this is a town hall story
it's on page 15 if you want to go to it
so uh uh Texas governor Albert signed
the the save women sports act which
prohibits transgender women from
participating in women's college sports
Governor Abbott stated women's sports
are being threatened some women are
being forced to compete against
biological men Alabama Governor Kay Ivey
also signed legislation Banning male
bodied athletes from competing in
women's sports emphasize fairness if
your biological male you are not going
to be competing in women's and girls
Sports in Alabama Republican state uh
representative Susan Dubose the sponsor
of the bill highlighted the inherent
advantage of being born male no amount
of hormone therapy can undo all those
advantages instances like transgender
swimmer Leah Thomas winning against
female athletes have sparked concerns
about fairness and equal opportunities
Tom you got two girls when you read the
story you're seeing what you know
Governor Abbott did we lived in Texas
for five six years what are your
thoughts when you see this story here
well first of all Constantine thank you
for your comments because I agree with
you I believe trans is about to break a
lot of uh the the will of a lot of the
resistance here is is not going away and
what I've been watching with with my
girls is a simple truth you can when you
just said Abracadabra Stacy there is no
time there is no test and there is no
validation required all I have to do on
a Monday and said I'm no longer Thomas
I'm Thomasina I will now be playing with
the girls Golf and I declare it that's a
so in sports when you allow that
emotional Declaration of who I feel I am
going back to what you're talking about
liberalism is based on feelings I feel
I'm a female now I'm allowed to go
compete and we've seen the outcome of
that a six foot three man still with
male genitalia as was seen by all the
women that were in the locker room at
the Ivy League championships I said wait
a minute they said he was a girl that
there
that's male genitalia hanging off this
guy and number one and number two he's
six three and he had size 13 feet those
are much bigger flippers than the
average the average woman is going to
have picture a shocking time exactly if
that picture says a thousand words
take a look at the cowboy hat in her
expression be glad she's not armed
ladies and gentlemen because that's an
angry cowgirl there yeah so the first
thing is you have to take out of this
there's no time there's no validation
there's no test it's an emotional thing
and so you need to protect them this is
swimming showed the performance now the
risk was showed up in October of 2022 in
Cherokee County in North Carolina where
the volleyball Spike knocked the girl
unconscious and she was having
concussion systems symptoms symptoms for
three weeks CAT scans proved it and then
what used to be a fairly liberal School
Board they voted 5-1 and said yeah after
we saw that volleyball Spike maybe you
can't declare a Monday you're a female
Common Sense prevails Common Sense
Prevail because they saw what happened
there well and you played this clip go
ahead and play the clip see what else
you got a concussion here watch watch
this lower right they should highlight
girl
watch this here she comes that's that's
the guy that's a male jumping boom she's
out she's done that's it
and so the school board saw this and
goes how long is the girl over there
nine weeks apparently she declared she
was female nine weeks and she's playing
and that's what Leah Thomas said I want
to win a championship so I declare it I
support and applaud a guy that I grew up
as a as a wannabe middle distance Runner
ran cross country and there was guys
like John Walker of New Zealand and
Steve ovet and Sebastian Co of the UK
were some of my my heroes Sebastian code
today is president of world Athletics
and said in March of this year we need
to protect women who are women in sports
and we need to have a time test a
validation test testosterone test
genitalia if you're gonna go do this he
said really we need a division for Trans
you said that's what we need we need to
protect the women here and he was very
rational about it common sense was
prevailing and I think what you're
seeing is Governors are getting hit by
the mainstream media because they're
coming out in favor of Common Sense look
you can't declare a Monday that you're a
girl and then go win a championship on
Wednesday and get your medal right
that's that's that's wrong and we need
to protect the safety of women and
Common Sense is prevailing and I think
it's great because my daughters look at
it and say so okay so what if Once Upon
a Time John Daly was a high school
golfer and decided he wanted to be a
girl he would have won all the state
championships I said Bailey that's right
and she said how is that fair right and
let's let's just be honest with each
other at the end of the day because
nobody has the ball sorry for my friends
to say it it's the it's the teeth some
of these guys that are competing
at the end of the day let's just come
out and be honest it's the trans
movement hijacked the LGB the lesbian
gay and bi movement and they completely
wiped out the feminist movement because
think about it great the point it's 100
because I know Pat I know gay people
that work here I know gay people I have
gay friends I have gay they are not
happy with this entire movement they
hijacked them well I'll see you and I'll
raise you I've probably into more trans
people than than most people a lot of
trans people are also being thrown under
this bus because this is being done not
on their behalf this is being done by
like activists a lot of trans people are
actually quite sensible they're like
look I'm not comfortable in my body I
want to live in a different way I don't
need you to pretend that I am literally
the opposite sex just just don't beat me
up and leave me alone exactly right and
I kind of feel sorry for them but I'll
make another I'll tell you a story that
will blow your mind which is kind of
relevant to this so my grandmother was
born in a gulag wow she was born in a
concentration camp
for political prisoners and one of the
things people don't know is once you're
released from these camps you would be
you would not be allowed to live within
like a hundred miles of any big city so
you'd have to live in some kind of
remote town and they all ended up
settling in these remote towns in the
middle of Siberia and the only people
that lived there were the former
prisoners of the camps a few of the
local native tribes of which there were
many and the guards from the very same
camps that the prisoners came to came
from and they would live in the same
building my grandmother's family they
lived in a landing across from another
apartment and another apartment there
was a guy who was a God okay and what
she told me is when Stalin died right
and he was exposed as having committed
all these terrible atrocities and so on
there was a Spate of suicides in this
town because these guards they all
killed themselves because they genuinely
believed they were doing the right thing
when they were beating these people and
torturing these people and that's one
you know hearing those stories from my
family that's when I really learned from
early days to get people to do something
terrible but think they're good you need
ideology and this is ideology this isn't
real this isn't Common Sense this isn't
people thinking about it critically this
is ideology and that's how you get to
the point where you've got massive guys
playing against little girls that's how
you get there because it's ideology
people aren't actually examining the
facts and and trying to get to the right
place they're going to news that
argument is going to remember remember
how how confident these people when they
were saying defund the police defund the
police defund the police remember those
guys oh yeah and now they're like we
never said that yeah yeah right we never
said that and then the house how quickly
these same feminists are gonna say we
never said that yeah we never said that
because the true feminists the biggest
feminist this last week protecting women
what's Greg Abbott and Greg Abbott is
not a feminist no if the definition is
to defend women Greg Abbott sat there
and said wait a minute we're not going
to let men beat up on women this is just
not fair 20 years ago that would have
been of course we're not going to let
that happen today that argument is
losing ground because of this whole uh
nonsense that they're spewing out no you
nailed the path they the trans they
hijacked the gay movement but then they
completely wiped out the feminists where
where are all those women I'll tell you
there are some so in the UK actually the
movement against this has been
absolutely spared by feminists by
feminists and you you have people here
like Megan Murphy uh and a bunch of
others but back to your point about you
know um defund the police this is how
strong ideology is I'll give you an
example that'll make you guys laugh you
know we don't have guns in the UK right
now a lot of knives yeah a lot but we
don't have guns and this is my point
right uh in the summer of 2020 BLM
happens we've got in central London
protesters in front of police officers
going hands up don't shoot
in front of cops you don't have guns
that's hilarious right that's the power
of ideology right stupidity is a great
point I'm learning a lot about you guys
today Tom I'm learning your hero uh uh
the runner from UK the more I spend time
with you the more I'm learning about you
your favorite poet you ain't nothing but
a hoochie mama hood rat hood rat hoochie
mama I didn't know that that's where you
were at but breaking news if you Rob
just texted me you want to pull up the
breaking news breaking news Hunter Biden
to plead guilty to three federal charges
this just came out 9 31 15 minutes ago
100 Biden son of Joe Biden will plead
guilty on three federal charges the
justice department said Tuesday in a
court filing The Plea will have
immediately revelations in 2024
presidential election Hunter writing
will plea guilty to two federal tax
misdemeanors and a one charge tied to
gun possession according to the filing
in a federal court in Delaware he will
appear in court to plead guilty to these
charges at a future date most likely a
week after
no no no this is nothing but look I mean
this is
this is a plea deal it's I'm assuming it
it is bringing attention to it it is
bringing attention to it which is a good
thing but it's nothing it's it's yeah
but I mean the main the meat pad the
meat of what and if you don't mind Pat
can I I wanna just with the whole since
we touched on it really really fast
let's we know for a fact we don't think
we know that the FBI withheld a document
from Congress that showed that Obama to
an Obama administration Biden took the
10 million dollar uh bribe through his
son Hunter bride in the crackhead uh
forcing them to fire the Ukrainian
prosecutor that was investigating right
Trump that let the Trump because Trump
was asking them to to investigate led to
his first impeachment on his laptop on
Hunter's laptop it shows the FBI not
only knew but they went on mainstream
and they called it what Russian
disinformation all the mainstream media
said it right so then FBI infiltrates
all social media Twitter we just found
out what the Twitter Twitter files
censored anybody talking about it during
The Campaign which is collusion and then
all the while they're investigating
Trump for the classified document
situation at Hillary and Biden did and
the whole time launching uh Russia gate
so none he's not going to get in trouble
for nothing on the laptop nothing with
the underage girls nothing with Barista
nothing with everything this is this is
a nothing burger what is he gonna go to
jail for this all I'm saying is when I
said 2023 is going to be the year of
Investigations it's the year of
Investigations and it's not done the
more you investigate that side the
retaliations we're going to investigate
your side this is going to go back and
forth there's going to be the the we're
not even halfway there to to the year
and there's still plenty more
investigations coming from both sides of
the other but investigation is about any
indictment any actual like going to jail
is anybody going to be like no
investigating a size
okay Hunter is Hunter going to go to
jail no is Biden going to get impeached
because they have audio of him
so what's the point no so investigate
what like Trump's not going to jail
Biden's not going to jail
right so your investigations and it's
going to sound like a bad poker game all
year long I'll see your Congressional
hearing and I'll raise you a subpoena
it's just going to go back and forth for
the sake of the news media let me know
when it's the year of the indict like
people in prison I want to know that
year the Year for accountability from
fauci to Biden 25 26 maybe 25 26. what
do you think percentage-wise of anybody
ten percent but it's maybe 25 26 not
it's not a very high like let me tell
you what happened here are you following
the whole thing with Peter Hotes with
Joe Rogan are you following okay
fantastic let me kind of walk through
with the audience and I'm going to come
to you and you you give your thoughts so
if yes perfect so that's the first three
so there's a Twitter war going on
over the weekend between Rogan hotels
RFK Mark Cuban jumped in and I had a
couple things to say as well so Peter
Ortez goes out and says Spotify has
stopped even sort of trying to stem Joe
Rogan's vaccine misinformation it's
really true that Anne Maryland just
awful and from all the online attacks
I'm receiving after this absurd podcast
it's clear many actually believe this
nonsense so this is a vice article
that's a Spotify stopped even sort of
trying to stem Joe Rogan's vaccine
misinformation by the way just so
everybody knows they just took down
rfk's interview with Joe Jordan Peterson
on YouTube
calling get vaccine misinformation this
just happened right but not how long ago
was that this just happened today or yes
oh yes this is probably a two-week
interview it's a recent interview it
could be more or less than two weeks go
to the next one so then Rogan responds
back Peter if you claim the RFK is
saying what RFK sin is misinformation
I'm offering a hundred thousand dollars
to the charity of your choice if you're
willing to debate him on my show with no
limit by the way at this point that
hundred thousand I matched a hundred
thousand Acme match to uh 150 I think
Tate put a half a bunch of people put a
hundred it's up to 2.6 million dollars
now three million dollars now no Ward
nothing's happening so after that if we
want to go to the next Elon Musk
response maybe Peter Hotes just hates
charity and then Mark Cuban jumps in but
let me see what's okay I'm going to ask
you very clearly are you willing to
debate because he responds back and says
Joe if you're serious about addressing
vaccines and the fact that a 200 000
unvaccinated Americans needlessly
perished during the awful Delta you know
uh coveted one waves including 40 000 in
our state of Texas because of all
victims fell to vaccine and some
disinformation I want to have that
discussion with you again Joe wants to
clarify uh I'm going to ask you very
clearly are you willing to debate RFK on
my podcast go to the next one
so then uh uh by the way RFK uh what's
it called Peter response back you have
my information you have this he keeps
going back to it the answer is no here's
what Mark Cuban says way to General a
lot go a little bit closer so I can see
it way to talk in general generalities
Joe not saying that there aren't a lot
of effed up things about Pharma that's
why we created Cost Plus drugs.com but
to ignore that same industry has saved
who knows how many lives is [__] and
you know it plugged for himself it's all
disrespectful to all the doctors
researchers and medical professionals
that dedicate their lives to saving
lives like Dr hoads the 800 000 plus
doctors in a country that believe
vaccines save lives you aren't trying to
find a ground truth on vaccines if you
were you would bring other people uh
trying to bully keyword bully Dr howitz
is ridiculous you have producers that
will prepare you same as RFK you both do
this on a daily basis Dr Hotes works
every day to find ways to help people
Joe you and musk and Twitter are
mainstream media online media and your
platforms have become everything
supposedly wrong with mainstream you are
driven by self-interest this is after he
plugged in his company yeah and the
first line just like the MSM has always
been accused of and you both have earned
the right you busted your asses to be
great and do what you do earn all you
accomplish but don't lie to yourselves
and all of us and tell us you are
different you aren't okay
so that's and then I respond back by the
way all of these tweets get a 50 000
likes a hundred thousand likes Joe's
gets 200 000 likes Millions on top of
millions of views so this is my response
to Cuban
Joe Joe trying to bully Dr Hotes
interesting let me address five issues
with your Tweet bullying number one
millions of Americans walk of all walks
of life were bullied into taking a
vaccine some for some course some lost
their jobs families were divided late
night host doing skits and syringes
mayor of New York City giving fries NIH
director flip-flopping on masks MSM
calling those who question the vaccine
conspiracy theories and you call Rogan a
bully okay number two capitalism what
makes capitalism work freedom to buy
sell try fail keyword is freedom you
told me 10 years ago Tom you were in the
room we were in Nashville when I asked
him what's his favorite book yep he said
at the shrug I even gifted you a first
print first edition of the book I think
November of 2015 when I interviewed him
at the American Airlines Arena in his
office yeah in his office a story of
dystopian American which Private
Business suffers under increasingly
burdensome laws and regulation of all
the people who know what happened the
last 30 years it's you we all know who
got destroyed in that book the small
business owner the man and woman who
risked it all okay they were marked
bullied silence how are how were laws
and regulations during covet how many
small businesses owners lost everything
you know the stats you know the numbers
you know you're against this I sometimes
wonder what you fear what is preventing
you from using your logic and experience
and Common Sense and that you have a ton
of to share your POV with your followers
number three debate what's wrong with
debate I kind of suggested for him to
run for 2024 and if he can go a little
lower you know about protecting these
guys let's not disrespect these people
that are doing this Wonder benefits in
America is the health care System my dad
37 years got a massive heart attack he
wasn't supposed to live past 65 we just
celebrated his 81st birthday but just
like cops 99 of them do the right thing
the one person who don't should we not
hold them accountable all Joe is asking
for is a debate if Dr horse is right
then what's he have to lose is he too
good for it you sure don't free debating
anyone why protect him debating is the
American way it helps us get closer to
the truth and the Muskie and Rogan
comparing them
talked about what happened before
October when we didn't even have Twitter
you know we could only debate in private
settings our RFK interview was taken out
two years ago content creators were
walking on eggshells musk isn't
silencing anyone who's arguing for
vaccines he's actually creating a
climate to have the debate just last
week by the way I don't know if you guys
saw this clip or not on MSNBC with Jake
Tapper and Rachel Maddow one is CNN won
his NBC they're like we won't air to
Trump speech because we already know in
advance that he's going to tell lies as
if Joe Biden only tells the truth that
sounds like a dictatorship where the
elite knows what's best for you and I as
if we can't think for ourselves a bit
arrogant and pompous don't you think
thank God for Twitter Spotify and Rumble
and other planets I gave him a credit
for plugging his company as a market I
respect your strategy of getting into
this threat to promote constructs Cost
Plus drugs a less than 12 small business
owner keep pushing the envelope we need
more voices by the way all of this is
going on all of this is going on
simultaneously guess what he's not doing
the debate and he made a video saying
well people can came to my front door
and I'm being harassed and I have to
kick people out and I'm doing made of
all them if everybody's going after and
protecting them all this stuff but at
the same time they're fearing the debate
what are you what are your thoughts
about this Twitter war uh Rob are you
able to pull up my tweets uh it's much
shorter I promise you
um it's uh like the hot take mixer I
called it but look uh I I don't think
it's good that people are turning up to
his door whatever whatever's going on
that we don't want that in society right
just someone had disagreement online
suddenly people are showing up at your
door I think it's bad but in terms of
the the the discussion I I made this
point in this thread that if I don't
know if you can scroll down a little bit
um it's like the hot mixer uh that I did
maybe yesterday it's just like keep
going
um there we go part one party can you
just read a Live code I do I do that's a
great picture were you in front of 10
Downing Street with that uh all right so
uh this is my take on it right and see
what you guys think many of his in my
opinion many of much of what RFK is
saying about the medical stuff isn't
accurate okay the why not uh is not
accurate the Wi-Fi is blood barrier
thing vaccines cause autism the the
maybe the vaccine injury is a real thing
my I come from a family of scientists so
my dad my Mom they're both biochemical
Engineers my dad used to make vaccines
in the Soviet Union didn't take the
covered one but in general you know he
can explain it to me what's going on
there like it's not my opinion and I'm
not a scientist but my random person's
view is I don't think many of the things
that RFK saying are accurate okay but
the part that wasn't mentioned in your
brilliant Twitter uh post is that uh
Peter I think he said that Rogan was
part of some kind of neo-fascist thing
with like other people which I think was
what Joe was doing he talked that tweet
down and Joe said I saw that tweet you
took down and I responded to it that's
right so talking to if you just go back
to to my thing talking talking to RFK
even though I don't agree with
everything you're saying doesn't make
you a bad person and the best way to
challenge misinformation is actually
good information if you just scroll down
to part two there's also stuff about
covert right like the vaccines were
pushed on people who didn't need them
with covert 100 most masks don't work
and we weren't allowed to say this right
and that is how the science wrecked
credibility in itself okay that's how we
got here so how do you fix it well
you've got to restore faith in the
science by acknowledging that mistakes
were made communicating honestly and to
me if you're a scientist and the biggest
show in the world says come and talk and
look if you think RFK is an idiot and
you're a scientist I mean that is a slam
dunk right come in explain to people why
he's wrong challenge some of the things
he's saying I mean RFK in the interview
himself says well this is beyond my
level of expertise you're a scientist
you can make can look
pretty silly very easily if you know
what you're talking about right and it
just it's frustrating that we've lost
the idea that we can have conversations
if we don't agree and we can have
debates and your point as a scientist is
to educate the public by coming in and
saying this is what's actually going on
and engaging with people's ideas instead
of just dismissing them so if it's not
Dr hotez I've never heard of him prior
to this Texas Children's chair he's a
chair he's a very very incredible guy
extremely incredible all good and if
it's not fouchy and if it's an
incredible guy for the people on the
left who use his mouthpiece to say if he
said it it's 100 right so
who's next in line because why is an
Abate a bad word why is it a bad thing
we have presidential debates we have a
high school debate clubs we don't have
presidential debates anymore no RFK is
not going to be debating Joe Biden we do
have presidential debates I mean whether
they get we were supposed to have three
lasts and we only ended up having two
people are avoiding presidential debates
so this whole thing about debates you're
right yeah what you're trying to say is
a good thing I'm just saying like this
is the American way we've constantly had
debates why is it being shut down now
this particular subject that's my point
is that they're they're they're
eliminating these essential debates that
need to occur because your your post is
absolutely right you don't agree with
RFK you're basically here saying Hey
listen I don't agree with what rfk's got
going on but I'd like to hear what he
has to say because the whole premise is
of a debate is to expose the other
side's leaks in their argument right and
if you're basically saying RFK has leaks
in his argument a lot of people believe
that a lot of people believe that he's
saying very accurate things the only way
to get to the truth is a debate right
the Bible the definition of debate is
settling a difficulty with a neighbor or
an adversary and that's the only way
you're going to get to this so if it's
not
who's next in line because for every RFK
out there there's a Robert Malone
there's a Dr Peter McCulloch that we've
had here these people are willing to
engage they're willing to debate and
they could be wrong but they're willing
to at least come to the table who's
willing to come to the table on the
other side well here's the part so this
this is what you're asking a
good question but you also know the
answer to the question okay I mean it's
not like you don't know the answer to
the question we all know the answer to
the question so here's a guy named Mary
Hassan you know who Mary is we know
medicine so he says uh noted conspiracy
theorist who has zero background in
medicine and public health and set covid
would be gone by April 2020 thinks he
knows more about vaccines than the world
renowned award-winning scientist who
helped create patent-free covet vaccines
for the poor medicine
is defending for RFK defending Peter
hortez to not debate RFK does that make
sense now here's the crazy part do you
know Mary Hassan just wrote a book
media-san just wrote a book okay that
came out
I want to say it's very recently that
this book came up this book just came
out to give the date February 28 of
2023. the title of the book is whenever
you are the art of debating persuading
in public speaking
you write this book then you're scared
shitless of Peter Hotes debating by the
way so let's just say Mary if you're
watching this since you're such a great
debater which you claim you are you
wrote the book we don't claim we are
that you're claiming you're this no
problem many question for you you don't
think RFK is qualified to debate him hey
Peter McCullough is
um
we got a few other people that for you
to have the qualification of doctors we
can get a lineup of people that would be
willing to debate Peter hottest so I
kind of hurts your argument doesn't it
and it kind of hurts your argument to
say rfk's not a doctor and you know what
it's pretty wild guys like him you know
probably who his hero was you know
probably who his hero was who's your
favorite American president of all time
you know what John F Kennedy did he was
an anti-establishment president what do
you think RFK is doing he's an
anti-establishment figurehead so the
people you admired you now you don't
like that family lineage because they're
pushing back on people like you and you
just wrote a book on debate dog and he's
just like horrible on what you're doing
man it's hypocrisy but Adam you named it
though it's like why wouldn't they right
constantly why wouldn't you because when
you when you're there and the camera's
on and it's you and it's fact versus
fiction you have to be real you're going
to get exposed and your lies and your
mistakes are gonna come out live and you
have to answer for yourself why would
they want to do that Adam you want to be
held accountable you want to have your
foot to the fire they can't do it bro
because all their [__] is going to
come out and I think one of the reasons
just setting aside the debate side of
this the the way that censorship of of
this kind of conversation has been
happening particularly during covet it's
like I get the sense that they just
don't trust the ordinary person to make
their own mind up and I think we've got
away from this idea that your life is
your responsibility like you're supposed
to go out taking different information
and then decide for yourself what you're
supposed to do and if you f that up
that's on you right and that's what
that's the way that Society is supposed
to function I don't want big daddy
government telling me how to live my
life on every aspect of it I want the
information I want to make my own
decision and if I get that wrong well
that's on me and I'll suffer the
consequences of that you hit the nail on
the head it comes down to individual
decisions because what basically was
plastered out there was a
one-size-fits-all basically agenda
everyone needs to do this yeah well it
turns out I mean there's a big
difference between an 85 year old woman
and a 21 year old dude right and they
and the same treatment should not be
implemented for those types of people
but they they lambasted everyone if they
didn't follow the doctrine and a lot of
confused people whether it doesn't need
to be politically you're just like I
don't know about any of this stuff these
are terms I've never heard before in my
life covid-19 social distancing's masked
up you're like
a debate would be the only way for
reasonable people to be like you know
what all right cool that's a good
argument right there I didn't think of
that yep all right good that's not for
me but my mom should consider all right
cool but that's the only way you get to
the truth and that's essentially the
problem here and why is it only in this
realm if there if there was like a rap
battle and someone wanted to yeah I'm a
better rapper than you Jason stage step
on stage let's see what you got and then
let's see what happens here if it's
actual boxing match you ever see these
things on YouTube where some guys
talking [__] online to a professional
boxers I'll whoop your ass it's like
find me at the gym Dude shows up at the
gym yeah all right put on some put on
some pads all of a sudden the guy
talking [__] gets the [__] kicked out of
him turns out but if you don't actually
show up to the debates how do you know
that your site has any validity
whatsoever now that's what I'm saying
who's gonna have the balls nobody to use
a little call back right there to show
up and at least defend your defend
yourself you're making me a great point
about you know the elite left thinks
they no matter better than the average
guy and they do not trust the average
people to make decisions in a democracy
we have a word for average people voter
so
and I think there's an opportunity that
we have to step back from all this and
let the voters you know vote and suffer
the consequences of what you voted for I
mean how many times did you see in a in
my own family I had grandparents that
voted for Jimmy Carter and then voted
for Ronald Reagan saying well we as we
the people got it wrong we were so mad
at Gerald Ford about Nixon we voted for
Carter there's the economy we got whoops
at the first opportunity they fired
Jimmy Carter that's the way it should
work when you have the liberalism that
sits there that says we're Elite and we
have predisposed knowledge and we know
better than you do that's an elitist
point and that's why the chasm that
doesn't allow a lot of debates to start
is coming from the conservative side
that says listen you seem to think I'm
evil I just think you're incorrect I
think there's value in your personhood I
just want to debate the point whereas
the liberal comes the other way and says
no you are an evil person that needs to
be deprived and moved off you know you
sit back and you pull back from that and
you say who's the Nazi now yeah and look
from my perspective I just think the
truth matters like let me ask you guys
this where did where did covet come from
Wuhan lab in China that we funded right
100 right if you said that if you said
that a year ago I was racist don't worry
about racist you would be shut down from
you you would be taken down oh you're
just like Trump who called it the China
virus you're a bad person you have to be
quiet and we need to know so it doesn't
happen again like if you thought the
pandemic was bad don't you want to find
out how it's not that don't you want to
fix the problem that caused it in the
first place and I don't want some 20
year old in California which is who's
making these calls right deciding what
we're allowed and not allowed to discuss
and debate and share right that to me is
crazy and look I'm not the left or right
I'm kind of an independent somewhere in
the middle I just care about the truth
can we get to the truth can we find out
how this happened can we find out what
the truth was about masks can we have an
honest conversation maybe we didn't need
to vaccinate five-year-olds right maybe
we did and in my opinion you know for
old people that if I Was 80 years old I
would have taken the vaccine day one the
moment it came out but you want to put
it on children just so you can feel a
little bit better you want to force
people to wear a mask all day that we
know it doesn't work like why are we
doing that's insane you're absolutely
right outside political right there and
and like to what Vinnie said when he
said 100 100 it came from a lab I don't
know that you don't know that you
believe that we need to invest what we
do what we don't know is nothing's a
hundred percent right I'm not 100
certain it came from a lab I'm also
definitely not 100 certain it came from
a Pangolin bang in a bat in a wet market
like I don't know and that's the whole
[__] point of a debate but this but
but you know why why I keep going to
that is because of the secrecy and the
height dude it's how many years later
when did covet hit
December 2019 2019 2029 December 20th we
are in June 2003 and we still don't know
right are you who who's a lot like are
you are you kidding me well this goes to
your accountability thing that we're
talking about when is China going to be
held accountable here for that well dude
hold on China gets accountable for
nothing they could they could fly spy
balloons and our government just goes no
no they're not even they're not taking
pictures mind you they're over a nuclear
missile base that I was stationed at
Malmstrom Air Force Base Montana no no
no China is running the show and we
still to this day right now how about
this Adam I'm 99.999 that it came from
there the real question is who leaked it
and why did they leak it let me add one
more thing let's be real with each other
you bring up China here thank God then
in America we have the ability to use
that word debate yeah you think they're
having debates in communist China you
think they're having debates in Russia
with Vladimir Putin do you think that
his approval ratings are somehow
magically a hundred percent without 20
years running so that's the whole
premise of what we do here in America is
be able to have these debates and for
these in these individual Realms where
no no debates here can't have debates
there can't have debates with reasonable
with unreasonable people it's like
that's the essence of the problem
because the whole Foundation of what we
do here in America is the ability to
debate yeah a good job of scientists is
to come out and educate the public right
to give them the information they need
to make their own decisions that's what
a scientist is there to do I would love
to see a scientist run circles around
RFK
and be like holy [__] Dr fill in the
blank name just schooled the guy that's
basically putting out all this
conspiracy theory around about uh
vaccines okay great wrong now the whole
world saw the RFK lose all right great
Shining Light onto the darkness over
here but if nobody's able to do that how
we all going to learn and we should give
to some love to Joe as well because the
one thing that I think he's really
established is he's a dispassionate uh
reasonable you know he's a genuine guy
so if they were to come together and
actually have the conversation he
wouldn't be like dunking on whoever was
on the other side he would actually host
that properly yes uh and and so people
don't need to be afraid of going in
there and having the conversation as
well you made a point in the middle of
all this about four minutes ago and you
said I don't want some 20 year old in
California right uh making a decision
for me you know what you're talking
about is the hundreds of sensors under
the guise of con under the title of
content moderation Specialists that were
sitting inside Facebook sitting inside
Google at over at YouTube and all this
that were making decisions on this and
so we're all talking about the
enablement to debate what you you
brought up is very important is we had a
whole Tech sector that was prohibiting
any presentation of any facts that could
become debate if they felt they came
from the wrong side so not only do we
have the issue of debate we had the
issue of the tech side deciding
pre-deciding the debate and snuffing
facts and opinions that come on the
other side that now they're sitting back
with the classic uh what's it the the
classic tweet blah blah blah blah oh
wait yeah do you guys know Jay
bhattacharya are you familiar yeah of
course right absolutely from absolutely
so so am I this is some some things that
happened during covert like didn't make
sense to me so in the UK we had this
situation where uh so Jay was one of the
Great Barrington guys and he was
basically a really well credentialed
really sensible Doctor Who was saying
we're going the wrong way in terms of
our response to covid and so this is a
guy who is a scientist being censored
online by people who aren't scientists
right and we're being told that this is
all about the science when someone like
him is not being taken seriously by
people in California who are just making
these decisions on a whim and in the UK
we had an even worse situation where
they were trying to get doctors they
were trying to say to doctors and nurses
if you don't take the jab you're going
to lose your job right and there's this
amazing scene where the government
Minister who is not a doctor is telling
a doctor to take the jab and you're
going does that make any sense to you a
non-medical professional trying to force
a medical professional to take a vaccine
that that guy doesn't want to take
right how how are we in the irony and
then we keep talking about the science
right where's the science on that
where's the science there is none
no we we need these debates to be taking
place right and by the way if there's no
debate taking place
uh it's only one cent it's a sign of
fear that something could be exposed but
people have to keep pushing listen we
have Whitney Webb here Whitney Webb is
doing all the research on what she was
doing with chelane Maxwell with you know
Epstein and Robert Maxwell all these
guys right
phenomenal job of what she's doing we
need people who are from the inside
where they knew this stuff wasn't gonna
work or the side effects and all of
these things we need those
whistleblowers to come out and say look
I'm a person that was pro-vaccine here's
what I did at this point of the game I
am not comfortable taking this but I
can't live with myself anymore I just
want to share a money this is going to
be a career ending no one's ever going
to hire me again no pharmaceutical
funding companies ever going to hire me
again here's exactly what took place we
need some people like that and by the
way I I'm firm I firmly believe that
it's going to happen I firmly believe
that's going to happen except I don't
know when the movie is going to be shot
I don't know if the movie is going to be
in the next two years three years five
years ten years there is going to be a
movie
made many movies made about this period
of 2020 to 2022 many many movies but by
the time they make it thought she's
going to be dead that's when these
movies are going to be made yeah and
then we're going to say that little
weasel yep if we get to see that that
little guy that did this by the way so
will Biden so Will trump
yeah there's a difference though no
there's a difference though the movie
for for the only difference between a
movie for Trump
versus the movie for a Biden versus a
movie for fauci is everybody had fauci
and Biden's back no one had Trump's back
everybody had their back it's a
different kind of a movie I know
sometimes it's politically correct to
kind of throw it in there and just count
just like this and just like that and
just like this
no the the one guy was muzzled we forget
he's he can tweet he doesn't tweet
anymore we forget he was banned from
Facebook Instagram YouTube as a
president by a social media company
what do we forget this who else do they
do this to but you mean to tell me
Biden's never told Lies when did they
ban this guy is this the is this the
first president that's ever told a life
he did tell a lie how about all the
other guys that came before him how
about have you seen what Barack Obama
looks like did you see him on
Charlemagne podcast I don't know if you
saw the one Charlemagne he does not look
good he does not look confident he looks
weak he looks like he's having a hard
time giving his argument to Charlemagne
like he's trying to defend but he can't
how did you go from well you know at
least I will go down as a president you
know and that whole mic drop on Fallon
on Camel whichever one it was and then
so well you know there's a guy in here
who believes and you know it's at the
dinner I don't know if you guys remember
that whole speech oh yeah you will never
be in a white house and then boom he
gets the White House and then you know
uh what's his name Snoop Dogg roast him
and says this ain't the first time a
trump put a black man out of his house
you know I don't know if you remember
when Snoop roasted him yeah yeah he did
what he did but how recent was the Obama
Charlemagne uh last week last week last
week you have any images of that Robin
how bad was it oh just go watch it it's
very uh I can guarantee you there's a
reason why this thing hasn't made it out
yeah there's a reason for that because
Charlemagne was asking the questions a
lot of people wanted to ask and
Charlemagne's a Democrat of course he is
but he did not look good on this
interview can you imagine by the way
here's what I want you to think about no
just stay right there look at this oh no
go back to where you were at you were
fine where you were at
anyways I'll try to find it to show it
to you but it's weird that it's not
popping up why is that yeah let me see
by the way it if it's if it's recent or
if it's
if it's the one that's a couple years
ago whichever one it was two years ago I
have to tell you
the conversation about blacks Obama
looked so weak and he's been out there
very quiet not kind of presenting
himself too much not talking about
anything these movies are going to be
made and we're going to look back one
day saying man we were definitely
manipulated during that two or three
year period let me ask you guys a
question so imagine big Tech existed at
the time of the American Revolution
is this country independent right now
I don't think is it absolutely not right
no the crown would have uh ensured that
hey these people are causing real world
harm by by creating stirring up division
right we gotta shut it down yeah King
George would have shot that thing that's
what you're saying because there's real
world violence based on what these
people are saying in their pamphlets in
the in the newspaper it could have been
called Big monarchy but no a great point
though by the way the the big if the big
Tech is around 1776 we aren't sitting
here having this conversation 100
yeah and that can comes back to the the
basic premise I was saying that the
foundation of America is to be able to
debate and to be able to basically State
your beliefs without being uncumbered by
big Tech censorship or Big King George
censorship basically saying no you can't
do that it's a great point that you're
making right now because the foundation
of America is being a dissident and
being saying yeah I don't think so this
whole no taxation without representation
think that'll work for me dog that don't
work for me King George and that's
essentially the premise here and we're
seeing it shift from the hard right to
the hard left and that's a scary thing
by the way Mark Cuban was seen we're in
assured have you seen the shirt he wears
where type in Mark Cuban question uh
everything or something like question
authority I think is what it's called
okay go to question authority this is
his shirt okay
question authority zoom in he's there
wearing a shirt question authority yeah
he's another question authority uh hey
Mr Mark Cuban why aren't you questioning
Authority okay the authority is NIH
The Authority is the guidelines of covet
you talk about question authority all
right you you have the mic
you're you're a triple threat you're a
guy that made the billions you're the
guy that runs a sports team you're a guy
that's had a very successful TV show for
how long now 10 years 15 years I don't
know what the number is it's been a long
time now as a drug company well he's got
a lot of different things the point is
killing it this is a guy that can argue
on both sides if this is part of your
brand why don't you question authority
we should question authority you bring
up such a good point about Cuban because
let's you know since we're going
revisiting history 1776 what would big
Tech be who would Mark Cuban been 20
years ago if you didn't have this
mindset this guy was a Trailblazer and a
disrupter in the NBA this guy was
getting fined the most fined owner in
history this guy was getting fined day
after day week after week for basically
doing what questioning the authority of
David Stern of the NBA hey I don't like
this rule fine hey I don't agree with
this fine he was getting fined left and
right you're looking at me like maybe
you don't know much about it I'm a huge
basketball Finance
left and right and the fact that it's
it's kind of him saying now no debate
debates are off the table it's just a
little ironic and people have people
people you know have memories it's like
this is one of the reasons that you know
you find such issue with Arnold
Schwarzenegger they made a choice and
the thing that that he has said but
forget your freedom
screw your freedom it's like this is the
guy who was the biggest advocate for
Freedom yeah and it's like people
remember what you stood for 20 years ago
and then the hypocrisy of what it stands
for now and and that's it okay he was
accumulated roughly four million fines
in the NBA yeah this was that dude yeah
this was the disrupter in the NBA this
was the guy calling out nonsense this
was the Trump of the NBA and now that
you've made your money you made your
billions you've written You've Won your
championship
you know you have a while why Mark Cuban
of all people why is he so pushing like
he even did it like we talked about Pat
when uh with Beasley the the wide
receiver for the Cowboys I'm not doing
he's like I'll pay I'll give you stock
and why is Mark Cuban so invested in
what is going in other people's bodies
at the end of the day he doesn't give a
[__] about the average person what's his
what's his incentive does he have does
he have stock and Pfizer is he bought
like I know he's he has a drug company
now but I don't think why are you so
worried though why is he still caring I
don't think this guy's worth I don't
know what he's worth building up his net
worth about four or five billion dollars
at this point I don't know what the
numbers well Pat why is he so pushing on
this why is he so 5.1 billion dollars
why is he still pro-vaccine and pro like
I don't get it what I'm not sure I'm not
worried that he's pro-vaccine I'm
worried that he's anti-debate you could
be Pro whatever the hell you want but if
you're not willing to at least
on say here's why I believe in this all
right you believe in this let's engage I
don't you could be Pro whatever the hell
you want if
you choose Joe Rogan and Peter hotez Tom
between Joe Rogan and Peter hotez who's
Authority
and what subject just no no no Joe Rogan
is not an authority in in he doesn't
summarize me to do he's a moderator so
between Joe Rogan and Peter Hotes who is
the authority is the objective Authority
decorated we can prove it experience
perfect in this case Mark Cuban defended
The Authority he didn't question the
authority exactly exactly period simple
as that I mean we can move on with this
conversation so a man who was a pillar
for questioning Authority isn't
questioning the real authorities
questioning the guy that's questioning
Authority Joe Rogan is questioning
Authority and you're not defending the
guy that's questioning Authority that
validates the shirt you always wore when
you were an NBA owner yeah I don't I
don't know about that so that's where
that's where the problem comes in here
where some people are wondering and
saying what is going on over here so
this leads me to something okay ESG what
is ESG
uh just last week Zero Hedge did a story
I'm sure you saw this the ESG rules
continues
page 10.
Legacy tobacco companies are posting
higher ESG scores than EV maker Tesla
here we go all right tobacco companies
such a can you pull up the Tweet please
rob put tobacco companies such as Philip
Morris
British American Tobacco have received
higher ESG scores than Tesla with Philip
Morris scoring 84 points and British
American Tobacco score 94 while Tesla
only scored 37 okay
tobacco companies have stretch
strategically embraced corporate
progress progressivism focused on
diversity initiatives and social justice
cause of while Tesla has been less
engaged in these areas tobacco companies
are gaming the system by embracing
corporate progress progressivism notes
the report Tesla report Tesla's lower
ESG score could make it vulnerable to
socially conscious activist investors
seeking board seats for Co removal Elon
Musk expressed frustration questioning
whether Tesla would face pressure from
virtue signaling investors like those
who targeted Exxon I posted this tweet
and I said so cigarettes do more good
for climate than a Tesla the hypocrisy
of ESG scores 10 37 out of 100 Philip
Morris 84. wow who's supposed to believe
this nonsense musk responded to this
actually if you get lower and he said
exactly but I mean this is a guy that's
actually helping the climate
the other guys are not and they're
getting a better what are your thoughts
about the story well this is why I said
this whole world view is anti-merit
right because it doesn't reward people
who are doing stuff it rewards people
who are signaling right like you you
take this box you've got this many
people from this demographic working at
your company that means you're better
even if you're selling people cigarettes
right and it's it and it creates a world
of perverse incentives and as you know
Patrick the people respond to incentives
if you put the wrong incentives in place
people are going to do the wrong things
well you ask the initial question the
ESG because on the surface it seems
ridiculous so if you look at it at the
the E the S the G there's basically
three different uh obviously prototypes
here so e stands for environmental waste
and pollution this is how they basically
score you if you want to learn the score
goes waste in pollution resource
depletion greenhouse gas emission
deforestation and climate change so
that's the environmental right social
employee relations and diversity there's
your Dei stuff right there working
conditions local communities health and
safety and conflict governance tax
strategy executive remunering
donations in political lobbying
corruption and bribery board diversity
and structure so it's one of those
things where you could on the surface
score very high probably on the
environmental but maybe you don't do so
well on the social or the governance
side of things so that's a getaway with
basically the Optics of big tobacco
getting higher uh ESG scores or better
ESG scores than something like a test
well and I don't know if you remember
when Elon was about to take over Twitter
there was this interview and they said
to him well what are your thoughts on
like what's your policy on diversity and
he was like I believe in the flat
meritocracy if you're good you stay if
you're not good you leave right that's
how every company in the world should be
run okay and that is anathema to these
people to them that's they freak out
when they hear that right because
they're anti-merit this is my point
right they don't want the company to be
as successful as possible they want to
take all their social justice boxes
because that's what they believe in
ideology
yeah and why does it only work in like
board seats and stuff like that so why
aren't women fighting or to be more on
construction sites and on deep sea
fishermen the hardest jobs in the world
it's like why aren't more women fighting
to do that it's because those people are
there for the meritocracy right there
like remember when people were up in
arms I think it was United where they
basically said uh we're we're hiring
uh all moving forward 50 of Pilots are
going to be women okay 50 of pilots and
they were like yeah but ninety percent
of the applicants are men yeah so it's
like if I'm me and I just want to get to
where I'm going from New York to Miami
bro I don't care if you're black white
yellow Puerto Rican Haitian Jamaican I
don't give a [__] get me from point A to
point B yeah I don't need being like
well did you check off the diversity
boxing for the job get me the pilot
who's gonna get me there safely yeah not
person checking the Dei ESG OPP score
well but I don't know if you can find
this story in the UK we had the
situation in the Royal Air Force where
they they had a diversity Drive they
decided to recruit a certain number and
then they basically said we're not
hiring any more useless white men oh God
right and then they just couldn't get
any [__] Pilots
people were like that's right and 160
white men did they actually sued the
government and and got paid out because
they were being discriminated against
because in the Air Force these are the
guys that drop bombs on our enemies I
don't care who
the color is I just care that they're
good at dropping bombs can we just get
some guys who can do that yeah you know
what I mean it I mean what are we doing
again common sense is going to Prevail
guys because more and more people from
all sides are going to sit there who are
Democrats who are Republicans who are
whoever they're going to say yeah you
know what I don't know man I'm just not
I can't see this thing making any sense
you know what I'm done I'm done with
this there's going to be more and more
of that happen you know what Patrick I
agree with you and I think a we got to
be optimistic but more there's actual
evidence for this so I get invited to
speak at different places including
corporate you know situations right and
they're all very scared to hear from me
about this because I show them this [__]
and I'm like this is what's going on and
they know it from the inside anyway and
the very few of them will say anything
publicly privately they all agree they
all know they all know this the
corporate people the people who are
running things they've been bullied into
this yes they're afraid to speak up
right we just got to give them
permission to do that by seeing that
it's not just the crazy is for making
these points there's some reasonable
people who want people of all Races to
to never be discriminated against who
want people to get along right that's
what I want I just want you if you're
good you get the job if you're not good
you don't get the job you hit the nail
on the head about people basically being
afraid to speak what's on their mind so
I do a show where I interview women on
the street right okay about not
prostitutes
sometimes but we're not discriminating
over here
don't care how they identify but I asked
them a series of questions okay what are
you looking for in a man what are you
bringing to the table why would you be
an ideal wife by the way do you think
men should participate in women's sports
and that's the one question that either
triggers them or basically they're like
listen I don't really want to answer
this uh not what's your body count not
you know what makes you a good wife it
should men be competing in sports and
that's that's the question like oh uh
yeah well I think that you know and
they'll give some sort of PC answer or
they'll say an answer and then the
interview's over I'll say hey thank you
for the interview is it okay if we use
this on and they'll say yeah but the one
part about the women's sports can we
maybe not use that or you know I don't
like what I said or by the way you know
I would have said something a little bit
different but you know I have a job so
it's like that is the one trigger point
so sometimes it takes getting out on
these streets talking to these people
that's the one thing that they won't
basically get behind on camera they
which what you're talking about now is
we're living in an age where social
media and mainstream media are divisions
in the army of the left that will come
and attack you these didn't used to
exist
um a very good friend of mine
um passed away recently he was quite old
but he was the exco ex president of La
Coke which was the largest Coke bottler
in America in the late 80s a gentleman
named Jesse Jackson and his organization
called rainbow push do you remember this
went into their offices when they were
basically based outside of Los Angeles
and a very Hispanic area called at that
time it was Riverside so out there in
Riverside very diverse area
and that's where La Coke had a
tremendous amount of employees and a
large bottling
Jesse Jackson's people wheel in they ask
for a meeting come to the conference
room and they ask for a quarter million
dollars to be their consultant because
they need to get to and they put this
number out it was like 25 or 30 percent
um African Americans in management and
you're obviously discriminatory because
of that and they said can you come back
next week Harold was a smart guy
um brought him back next week and says
okay we need to do a press release
together because we're going to lay off
uh 17 I think it was almost 17
um
um Hispanic people that are in
management jobs as well as the following
and then we're going to announce that
we're doing this and we'd like you to be
at the press conference when we
announced this that you've come in here
you can be your consultant and these
people are going to be laid off and
reconstitute this racially toward your
your target here when they said that
guess who left
Jesse wanted no part of that press
release no part of that Pros well they
bluffed him so they bluffed him right
out but they didn't have the mainstream
media they didn't have social media so
this has been going on for a while it
was a Shakedown and there was a book
eventually written about this simply
called Shakedown where there's money in
this people are going for the money that
are not true believers and so we also
have with all the things that are going
on here and the liberal media and social
media coming out there that the people
you're talking about that will say
things in private are scared to death of
the of the Public Public backlash that
happens from the other side and that's
what people are running from now they're
running from that and and you have to be
able to stand up to it and you have to
stand up to it and say it's hard to do
today so hard if you've got a job above
you yeah yeah if you've got people above
you yeah if if you're working for and
like it this can be a weird advice I'm
gonna give this is the worst time ever
to Fortune 500 company ever this is the
worst time to work for a company that is
on the stock market that is asking money
from
Vanguard State Street and what do you
call it uh Vanguard Black Rock yeah
black garden because
you have to you have to abide by certain
rules and guide guidelines or else
you're being silenced the employees
being silenced you're afraid to say like
you know he got banned on Instagram okay
for what for Adam Adam's not a guy
that's gonna go out there and say stuff
to get banned if there's anybody that is
not a guy that should give it he gets
panned okay guess what is he going to
get his account back 100 is going to get
his account back is it going to take a
week two weeks three weeks a month two
months of course if you work at
Instagram and you follow the content
reach out we're already dealing with a
couple but if you do DM me if you work
at Instagram or send us an email info
valuetainment.com and put Adam insta and
we'd love to follow up with you because
we got some guys on the inside that's
working on it but anybody but here's the
part you're gonna end up getting your
account back why am I confident he's
going to get his account back we have
eyeballs we have distribution we have
audience we have leverage we have we
have ways that we're going to get you're
going to see his account is going to
come back
but how many people who don't have that
who have 13 other followers 1800
followers 2 000 followers there is no
Instagram customer service line what are
they gonna do by Design
those are the guys that are afraid who
don't want to post anything they're
worried because if somebody takes them
down they don't have that help to get
somebody to get their account back those
guys are not protected so no I I think
it's a it's a time where the the people
that want to get like a guy calls me
again this is another guy this is an
athlete you know who he is he calls me
he says I'm not happy about what's going
on we have a conversation together it's
okay so what do you want to do he says
well I'm getting all these other offers
and monies are coming in from
sponsorship I mean just staying quiet
but I can't stand the fact that I'm
doing this and I said how much I said do
you have the kind of money where you
don't give a [__] if you get any more
money he says I do so I said so what do
you want to say but I want to get more
money I said do you have other ways of
making money without having to rely on
the machine not yet
what do you tell this guy
build you've got to build your own thing
yeah so so it's either go talk go a line
to get backing go somewhere that they're
gonna deflect for example Rogan has a
reached Saint status we're very good we
have one of our best exchangers him and
I yesterday best ever and and he's a guy
that I think he is a the most necessary
voice that's causing these types of
conversations and we got his back I mean
this is a guy that's you know you're
you're a fighting Authority and you're
questioning Authority guess what we
defend your ability to question
authority and see what's right and
what's wrong we're going to defend that
but Rogan's got Saint status right he's
UFC Dana White Endeavor all those guys
and and you know what they know what
brand is here's what Dana White's brand
is can you imagine if Endeavor calls
Dana White and says hey Dana you got to
kind of take it easy with this what do
you think Dana's going to say
what are you talking about right but
because that's how he's
created his brand from day one and I
said well there can be no sports in
America and UFC cannot have any fights
for two years hell no we're going to
freaking Dubai yeah we're going to Abu
Dhabi what yes and the only sport that
was playing at the time was what
UFC guess what we watch we watch UFC
instead of basketball you know fans
cardboarded face you're watching a
football game saying what the hell is
this show the weakness so meaning Dana's
brand is say something right hey look at
Dana he hit his wife I did and I'm
embarrassed by it and I have to live
with us for the rest of my life and the
more people that I'm most embarrassed
with is my kids do you realize I have to
face this for you nobody here is going
through harder times
so the brand of Dana's like I don't give
a sh so this is like for the small guy
who's working at a Fortune 500 SMP file
this is why Patrick
there's more responsibility for people
who do have a voice and for people who
do have a platform to actually step up
that's why because 100 because they can
100 agree and so we've had you know
videos taken down on YouTube we kick up
a fuss in the Press because we can boom
comes back we had a bank account shut
down a few weeks ago uh we don't know if
it was political or not but again big
stink everywhere online we get it back
what if you're an ordinary person yeah
so that's why people who do have a
platform your athlete friend like if
you've got enough money you've gotta
you've got to speak up and if you don't
yet you don't have that Independence and
build it go out and actually get
yourself to a point where you can speak
because it's important right like if you
feel so bad doing what you're doing no
millions are gonna make you feel better
about it you know you know you know it's
crazy though you know what I tell these
guys they call me and they tell me the
fear of losing everything I said listen
you know
Ali wasn't afraid he stood up
x y z wasn't afraid a lot of these guys
weren't afraid what happened what kind
of a guy do you want to be known for do
you just want to be known as a guy that
made a half a billion dollars
or do you want to be known as a guy that
your kids want to gonna look back and
say my dad took a stand and he was not
afraid to stand up and voice his opinion
you got money that's right you got
plenty of money what do you so well yeah
I know I understand what you're saying
but again this is it's it's it's so easy
to talk hard and you are
but that guy has to make the decision
and there is a fear of making that
decision and there's a lot of things you
lose when you make that decision but
there's something you get too you get
something which is yeah you you know
yourself as a real man in that moment
well look at the at the end for longest
time I create I was creating content
people would say Pat you know Patrick's
talking politics my team's about to lose
now I've seen this before it's the
mistake pbd is making he's officially
talking politics he's about to lose his
entrepreneurship audience
I sat there I'm like
you know
I don't do well with control I don't do
well with authority you yeah no I listen
more hey Mario don't let me talk
politics and I'm talking politics
finally I'm like listen man here's what
we're gonna do we have entertainment
business all the stuff that we're doing
great we have pbd podcasts we're talking
freely about all the issues and I just
want to talk to people about real issues
in life that's going on let's talk shop
and you agree disagree I'm going to be
challenged oh you were wrong [__] I was
wrong I was like you were wrong we were
both right and wrong okay great let's go
research this but what it's doing is
this the evolution of the audience grown
with us is saying I'm also kind of going
through the Journey with you guys right
but at the end of the day the problem is
going to be by those of us that can
actually have a voice and we can push
back and we don't because we're worried
about losing a sponsor hey those guys
going to give us money what about this
we don't need any sponsors we've had a
lot of weird sponsors come in we have
multiple alcohol people that will come
and tell me we'll pay you you know
million dollars two million dollars
three million dollars like dude I'm the
worst sponsor to do alcohol okay I I
drink the old-fashioned once a month
yeah and I want you to take a picture
every time I drink an old-fashioned from
the moment they bring it to me to the
moment I finish drinking it it goes from
this much to how much uh Adam you see it
every time yeah I usually finish
so but the point I'm like I can't do
that man hey coffee you guys want to do
coffee sponsorship we can't do that but
I agree with you we ought to be a little
louder I want to go to the story thing
about that I'll let you wrap up and then
I want to go to the story with what's
going on with California parents who
don't affirm gender Yeah well yeah just
to Circle back you brought up the fact
that my Instagram account was taken and
uh I really empathize with everything
that's going on with Tate because they
don't give you a warning
there was no hey this is the reason why
there was no hay in order to contest
this uh press this button it's just gone
man and I can't tell you how it feels as
something that's worked I only had a
hundred thousand uh followers on
Instagram but I've had it for 10 years
I've worked my ass off started doing
basic money tip stuff all the way to 10
years later now I'm doing interviews
with pbd and Andrew Tate like the the
progression it feels like someone comes
in your house
robs everything takes it over locks the
door and you have no ability to
basically say hey what's going on here
guys it's like a raping of the highest
kind and it's uh ultimately what I've
learned from doing this show is the the
first amendment in America here in
America
is the greatest thing we have and if
you're if you silence someone and if you
muzzle someone and you can't say what's
on your mind I'm not a crazy person I'm
not a far-right conspiracy theorist not
far less I'm kind of like you
Constantine I'm very very much in the
middle very much and you know what's the
famous Voltaire quote like I disagree
with what you're saying but I will
defend vehemently your right to say it
that's how I feel right now and it's a
very weird thing and last thing you know
the famous quote like the first the
famous poem first they came for the
hungarians and then I was in hungarians
and I give them they came for the the
labor union and I wasn't a labor unit so
then I didn't say anything then they
came for the Jews and I wasn't Jewish I
didn't say anything it's like then they
came for me and there's no one left to
say anything and that's how I feel it
was like yeah during the January 6th
stuff I was like yeah I don't know it's
not my thing during the covet thing yeah
that thing it's like no no now that it's
happened to me it's like holy [__] here
it's like if they'll get you they can go
for anybody at any given point for any
reason you're gonna get your account
back
it's the hundreds of thousands of people
that will never get their accounts back
from which is sad which is sad those are
the people that will never get their
accounts back because they don't have a
voice or backing together accounts and
that's a very sad thing I love your
confidence I'm gonna get my account I'm
telling you right now you're gonna get
your account back there is no question
about it but it's going to take a minute
until we there's a fast strategy or slow
strategy the fast strategy is tomorrow
you come out and tell people that you're
transgender yeah I'll do it right
I love what Constantine said in that
speech can you pull up the speech on him
and his wife getting pregnant 15 months
ago of course this is a while back but
yeah press that watch this part that's
my favorite part of speech go ahead 15
months ago my wife got pregnant not me
because we're old school
[Laughter]
Oxford is like our Harvard yeah right
and this is a their debating Society
they've had former U.S presidents Prime
Ministers all of that come here and they
asked me to speak at a debate about has
World culture gone too far and to be
honest with you I'm kind of getting
tired of talking about wokeness because
I'm just like we need to get through
that to the post-work conversation
because anti-woke and woke to me are
both like pretty crazy right now you
know what I mean we could we just got to
get through it uh so I I talked about
that but from a different angle it you
know you heard it earlier talking about
climate change and so on and just saying
you're not being effective and my friend
Melissa Chen I don't know if you guys
know her she tweeted something a long
time ago that really stuck with me she
said you cannot stay woke if you build
anything whether that's muscle whether
that's a business and whatever because
because once you start getting into the
real world and you start trying to do
things you understand it's not all black
and white there's trade-offs you go this
way you're going to lose this you go
this way you're going to lose that right
and it shows you a little bit of the
Nuance of reality uh and it forces you
to confront the world as actually so
Melissa Chen is great yeah I love the
part about you you talking with John
Anderson about you know Thomas sold
there's no such thing as Solutions but
trade-offs that whole concept you were
going back and forth with Thomas so a
legendary mind and something else yeah
crazy okay let's talk about California
so another state just banned no no not
this one what page is that on page is it
uh
okay page 16
uh okay there you go California bill
could result in loss of custody
for parents who don't affirm children's
gender this is an actual law they're
passing I thought it was a joke as well
so a video in which a patent an attorney
obliterated representative Wilson's Back
peddling on child abuse claims and vague
terminology if you want to have that put
that clip up Rob you got the Twitter
link here California ab957 known as the
tgiu empowerment act could lead to child
abuse accusations against parents
involved in custody battles if they do
not affirm their children's chosen
gender identity the bill initiated on
Assembly women Lori Wilson aims to
prioritize the parent who best affirms
the child selected identity and custody
disputes however the legislation does
not explicitly Define what affirmation
entails to proposed law considers
affirming a child's gender identity as
part of their health safety and Welfare
if grants the court it grants the court
system the ability to make custody in
business visitation decisions based on
appearance affirming of their child's
gender identity and by the way this lady
gives us talk you don't have to play the
whole thing but play the first 30
seconds maybe a minute and then we'll
respond to it I am Aaron Friday lead of
our duty an attorney and a mother of a
girl who used to believe that she was a
boy
ab957 is the first bill in the nation to
codify into law that a parent who does
not affirm the gender identity of the
child is abusive there is no Nuance in
this bill it matters not the age of the
child the absurdity of the identity
adopted comorbid mental health issues or
persistence Family Court judges will be
compelled to favor the child who will
affirm the child's delusion parents can
easily gain the system and use gender as
retaliation against each other what
happens when one parent will socially
affirm the child but will not agree to
medicalize does the parent willing to do
more transitioning prevail
ab957 unambiguously states that the
health safety and Welfare of the child
includes a parent's affirmation of the
child's gender identity you can pause it
right there Sean what's your reaction to
this
that
um the reaction is Lori Wilson is
pandering to the Mob
um where she probably gets donations and
things and what she's putting is it
custody is such an important thing you
know equality of custody and it is so
important that parents both get a fair
Shake because kids are going through a
stressful thing called the divorce kids
at 10 years old are being asked to take
a stance against mom or dad buy mom or
dad this puts kids in incredibly
stressful situations in the first place
and now you're asking a kid to put
something else on the table or be
manipulated on something else and then
the parents go after each other look
divorce and custody battles in this
country are are flamethrowers enough and
now this lawyer is correctly pointing
out that this bureaucrat Lori Wilson is
putting AB 957 out there that in
addition to do you support public school
or private school do you let them hang
out with their friends or Nazi let them
have a cell phone or not all these
things come up in divorce cases divorce
cases and custodies have been flipped on
what age would you allow the kid to have
a phone to text their friends and judges
are going one parent or another on on
freedoms and Disobedience now you're
just putting Another Log on this great
big fire an absurd log which she points
out does not have clear definitions of
what all this affirmation is this is uh
this is lunacy under if you step back a
little bit even more Tom look I mean we
talk about gender affirming care I mean
we don't have that term but you guys
have here let me just step back a little
bit and ask a simple question why can
you not have sex with a child
it's illegal they're underage but why
but why is that
because the child can't consent to sex a
child cannot make the decision to have
sex which sex is a normal thing for
human beings to do but a child can
consent to change their sex
is that what is that what you're telling
me correct a child can is capable
they're not allowed to drink they're not
allowed to smoke they're not allowed to
take certain drugs they're not allowed
to get married they're not but they are
English in the Army right but they can
make this decision is that what you're
telling me
and if if you don't as a parent affirm
them the government is going to take
them away and give them to what
what did you see Bill Maher's speech on
uh on he sums up the speech this way
talking about exactly what you're
talking about he said when I was young I
wanted to be a pirate I'm so glad that
my parents didn't send me out for eye
removal and peg leg surgery right yeah
exactly I and I have a personal
experience with this because I have
three younger sisters the middle one
when she she was seven years old this is
like in the in the 90s back home so like
you this thing wasn't around right and
she said to my mama I'm a boy and she'd
run around claiming she's a boy well
she's grown up now she's the most
feminine beautiful young woman just got
married last year in Armenia to an
Armenian guy like when she was seven she
thought
she was a boy okay kids don't know what
they're doing that's why they're kids
that's why we protect them they all have
faces they have to be protected from
each themselves too right where does
this idea come from that they can just
suddenly decide what they are and we
gotta throw the whole way of the medical
system add them to facilitate that yeah
I'm so glad you shared the the story of
your sister because when you humanize
these stories it's like all right these
are real people with real stories and
there's a beginning middle and end to
these stories I grew up with two girls
that were like the two girls that played
with all the boys in sports okay
fast forward they were like tomboys we
all remember tomboys right this was a
this was a thing that we're all very
familiar with now what happened to these
two girls one ended up growing up
becoming a lesbian she's a feminine
lesbian she's a woman okay the other
girl we ended up dating in high school
she's a woman in full-on which she's now
married with kids but like these stories
when you're seven you're 10 you're 12
and you think that you're a pirate or
you think that you're a boy you're gonna
evolve like I thought I was a dinosaur
when I was seven years old I'm not
walking around you know on two legs over
here with a little arms out here but if
you don't give children the ability to
grow up and evolve and you basically
castrate them or cut them off or
harmonize them you don't give them the
ability to figure it out later on in
life and that is the truest crime well
my buddy Francis so that we do
trigonometry with uh he used to be a
teacher for 12 years
um and he always tells the story he says
I had this kid who's about nine years
old and I said to him what do you want
to be when you grow up and the kid
looked him when I want to be a dog
that's kids yeah exactly right
that's that's the level they're
operating at you know at least you
didn't see cat
we don't got to go there by the way this
is somebody just commented GM and said
Jeff younger's ex-wife took his son uh
he gave a Super Chat to to who took his
sons to Cali for that exact reason he
would be a great man to talk to if you
type in Jeff young ex-wife you'll see
the story you guys have seen this before
they get a divorce a wife moves to
California to take advantage of the the
law so his their son could transition
okay pretty wild when you think about
some of these things that's taking place
but by the way this leads to
Newsome's media blitz fueling
presidential talk page four he was on
Hannity and a lot of people said he
destroyed Hannity a lot of people say
that that it wasn't Hannity's best luck
Newsome went in there ready and looked
strong California governor Gavin news
some increased media presence has
sparked speculation about his
presidential Ambitions with Democratic
strategist Steve maviglo suggesting I
buy that he supports the president but I
also think that he wants to be there in
case God forbid there needs to be an
alternative if something happens to the
president or if somebody else mounts a
challenge Newsome's recent confrontation
with Florida Governors Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis and his media engagement
including interviews with foxman's Sean
Hannity as intensified the speculation
Newsome has called DeSantis a small
pathetic man uh has and raised the
possibility of pressing charges against
Florida officials Fernand amandi a
democratic pollster notes that newsom's
attacks on the Santas have been well
received by democrats in Florida and
nationally
so what is this a publicity stunt is
this a a preparation for presidential
run what do you think is going on here
with Newsome Tom uh I think he's this is
a run and we're just waiting for the DNC
and we've been talking about this on
this podcast with some factual things
that have been coming up the DNC hasn't
taken a stance on certain things the DNC
has been leaking at certain times
non-favorable Biden articles to people
like the New York Times there is a back
room undercurrent going on here that if
you look at it you do not have to be a
conspiracy theorist you look at it he is
saying I'm running and he is putting his
group together but the DNC and the
Democrat machine is not fully supported
that yet and Newsome I believe is
standing at the door saying come on guys
wave the flag green flag here let's go
racing wave the flag I think that's
exactly what Newsome's doing and he's
positioning himself he's taking
advantage of not just photo ops but
places to put an opinion out that is a
national uh political position I think
that's what's going on here Newsome is
just waiting for the DNC to open the
door and say game on I actually disagree
with Tom on this and we'll see how this
plays out the debate one
I think this is not uh jocking for
position I think this is an insurance
policy God forbid Biden is not equipped
we don't I mean he falls exactly God
forbid that Biden is not able right it's
an insurance policy words correct well
they're gonna still prop him up and he's
still gonna be the guy that he's gonna
be running in in 2024 but I think
whether it's the DNC doing this whether
that's his uh internal team that's
basically saying hey stay ready stay
fresh because it's almost like an
athlete saying hey we don't know if MJ
is going to be able to play tonight
buddy all right now I'm not definitely
not comparing Biden to MJ all right that
just being out there but just in case
he's not ready
he still put up 45. but just stay ready
just got hurt are you ready yeah so by
the way I think uh if you know if you if
you watched any of that stuff that he
did with Hannity he dismantled Hannity
it was not a good look for Hannity on
his own show if you were just tuning in
and saw that you would thought you would
think that was the Gavin Newsom show and
that Hannity was the one basically
backpedaling and trying to answer
questions uh to his comments about the
Santas we've met DeSantis uh he is
neither small nor pathetic but he is I
can confirm amen so that is uh okay that
that is by the way this this old polls
is favoring Trump more and more and
DeSantis is flatlining based on numbers
that just came out uh Trump cruises the
Santa's flat lines in polling even after
bombshell indictment this is political
story that just came out so the
sentences marketing teams got to get to
work RFK strategy just so you know if
the sentences team is listening here's
rfk's strategy he's getting more
eyeballs than DeSantis rfk's going to
podcasts long form podcasts and he's
sitting there in the line of fire taking
questioning let me say that one more
time the sentences campaign this is our
governor the reason why we moved to
Florida is because of the great
phenomenal job he did but he's got to
get in the firing line and start taking
the questions go on the top 20 podcasts
out there long form two hours and talk
and sell and debate sell America sell
the future sell your family sell what
values and principles and that momentum
will come back up because this strategy
the old school 1990s way of running for
office does not work today and RFK is at
15 points without a single person on
mainstream media giving them anything
yeah he's at 15 points RFK last story
before we wrap up Andrew or you tell the
more you sell baby Andrew Tate go to The
Last Story here with if you want to pull
up the story on Andrew Tate and what
just happened with him being charged
this morning
uh do you do you have the story wrap
um if you just want to go to Valley team
and it's right on the cover of it just
happened by Tim and go to the cover
yeah there we go
go to vitamin.com Rob just go to bed
there you go perfect how did you hear
what RFK said on that what RFK said at
the end of The Joe Rogan podcast he goes
I am not talking vaccines period from
here on out like in any podcast he goes
I'd say what I had to say I'm done
because he knows that they're gonna take
him down uh so here we go Andrew Tate
Romanian officials filed charges against
the Tate Brothers the controversy
continues so as social media influencer
Andrew Tate has officially been charged
with rape human trafficking and forming
an organized crime group to sexually
exploit woman according to BBC's news
and Tate's apparent number one fan
writer Lucy Williamson uh Andrew's
brother Tristan is also facing the same
charges a Romanian judge now has 60 days
to inspect the file
and with their case being sent to trial
upon hearing the news the Tate Brothers
media team responded while this news is
uh undoubtedly predictable we embrace
the opportunity it presents to
demonstrate their innocence and
vindicate their reputation the
indictment added that it allows us to
present a comprehensive body of evidence
diligently collected and prepared over
time which will undoubtedly substantiate
the brother's claims of Innocence there
are separate charges still under
investigation which could lead to a
separate indictment including money
laundering and trafficking miners both
brothers continue to claim their
innocence having denied all allegations
that trial is not expected to start
immediately and is predicted to take
several years and if you want to see the
interview click below several years yeah
well listen that story is out here's how
it works they've said it the both
brothers have said if you have anything
with us go to the police create a report
come with your story if they've done
anything the law is going to do their
part if they've not done anything and
they're playing this game
Romania almost has to do something to
show that yes we were right the last you
know since April of going back and forth
for however long it's been 14 months
there is something there it's been
allegedly allegedly allegedly now it's
we got to convict him because everyone's
been saying when are you going to
convict them so those whole four 14
month Witch Hunt guess what the real job
just starts now they're lawyers can
officially do their jobs now for the
last 14 months they literally couldn't
do anything because there was nothing to
fight off there's no paper to attack
nothing no paper now excuse me now
they're gonna go after him and this
thing's going to take a while before we
learn anything about are you following
the story with Tates a little bit what
are your thoughts on this well I I just
want to see what happens now right you
said it yourself it's allegation
allegation to now the noun we got to see
what the reality is and everyone's
innocent until proven guilty but if
these charges are serious let them be
investigating we'll see what happens
yeah the Law's gonna it's on the law now
to do their part and it's on their
lawyers to do their part it's going to
be uh but it's going to be a long
process I don't think we're going to get
an update in a month or two I think this
thing's going to go for a while so if
there's anything I've learned from from
Tate is that the Matrix is real and
their Matrix attacks are a real thing
and they will do whatever the hell they
want to do to bring you down they will
try to find they'll spend months
years going going through all your stuff
to find anything they will go back 10
years ago to some girl and some Pub that
you may or may not have met nameless
faceless woman and allow her to
basically give her a story and you're
like I don't have no clue who this
person is but they will use that against
you and they will and will basically use
the system talk about the system being
weaponized and politicized it's exactly
what's being is going on here and let's
just remind each other Tate predicted
this he basically said I'm calling my
shot right here it gave the old Babe
Ruth this is what's going to happen
right here and just think about it if
you're a criminal just in any in any
realm we all saw Good Fellas the number
one rule lay low lay low the the advice
was yeah keep your mouth shut the advice
was not go start a podcast just shoot
off at the hip say everything wild that
you've ever done in your life business
financials sexual social and let
everybody know all your deepest darkest
Secrets if you have something to hide
you don't do that [__] yeah okay it just
doesn't we're living in a [__] clown
world right now and this is the tip of
the Spear of clown Central right now
welcome to Comedy Central yeah and being
I mean think about being around them for
all those hours that we were and hearing
him and talk to him I'm not I don't
judge people but just the character in
his eyes man like just having those
moments I mean he knew it was coming but
I believe that they're Innocent but I
mean he's there's no surprise here
there's no surprise and they're in
Romania brother remember they even I
think well it's one judge there's no
jury yeah you don't speak the language
how are you supposed to even defend
yourself you know what the lawyers are
thinking right now finally we can get to
work yeah let us do our part now show
the evidence and get to work uh at the
end either the side that can't stand
these guys is going to say I told you so
we were right look what they did here's
who they are or the other side is going
to cause them to get their voices to be
10 times bigger than it is today it's
just gonna Elevate if they end up coming
out Innocent but one of the sides is
going to win and Tom's gonna tell and by
the way thank God that there's platforms
like Rumble like there's platforms like
Twitter at least he can get his voice
out there imagine if there was nothing
none of that and he had to rely on
basically big Tech censorship to get his
voice out there that is scary you're
exactly right Adam two words Duke
lacrosse
took two years but they were innocent
but look what they did to them along the
way exactly yep so and and by the way
you know we have to give credit where
credits do both of their interviews are
still on YouTube as of right now if it
changes great credit to YouTube their
interviews are still on valuetainment
and they're still there for people to go
listen to them okay and after the
indictment the other 45 minutes that was
not released to the public will be
released if you want to hear that 45
minutes that we have to cut text the
word Tate to
310-340-1132 and if you enjoyed our
guest today as much as we enjoyed him
today click on the link below in the
description Rob let's drive them to
trigonometry end the book to stay in
contact with this man because his voice
is also necessary he's not only funny
but he also knows how to reason and it's
easy to listen to it's been great having
you on the podcast man appreciate you
for coming out I appreciate you
gentlemen thank you so much take care
everybody